je rappelle que les stratégies de
confinement sont généralement des
stratégies en raison de notre capacité
d'accueil dans l'hôpital public
des lits de réanimation y en at il de
nouveau qui ont été ouverts depuis le
premier confinement que nous avons vécu
non alors juste des moyens nouveaux cas
et revenait ce soir pour vous leur
confinement on y va tout droit
la janais peur toutes les statistiques
sur la moi vous savez il faut écouter
les scientifiques un faut savoir aussi
dans ces cas là moi je participe à
l'obscurantisme ambiant il ya des gens
qui des scientifiques alors ils étaient
près que ce qui nous aide pas parfois
c'est qu'ils ont parfois des opinions
contradictoires parce que c'est une scie
à la fois des choses scientifique puis
aussi des projections des
excursionnistes les conséquences dures
confidente non mais déjà il me semble
moins de ce que je dis que nous allons
vers une situation de blocage
d'évolution significative
indiscutablement et nous allons devoir
les verts un continent et moi je suis
d'avis que d'anciens on dise mais en
confinement
j'ai envie de dire à l'image de ce qui
avait été fait la première fois mais
avec aussi des revenus de remplacement
parce que nous sommes dans une situation
où - là cette fois ci c'est l'élu de
seine-saint-denis qui parle ou le choc
il est particulièrement fort dans
certains départements c'était mon cas la
première fois un taux de mortalité 130%
plus important que l an auparavant ça y
est on a beaucoup parlé des premiers de
cordée mais les premiers de corvée ont
été particulièrement touchées et des
mesures qui sont prises je vous vois
vouloir marcher des français demandé
pardon mais passé la parole à l'ats mais
bien par adolphe j'étais je termine là
dessus c'est car actuelle le couvre feu
de 21h00 qu'une concentration de
salariés qui vous devant respecter des
consignes se concentrent notamment dans
les grands centres urbains sur les quais
des métros dans l'est etc et qui amène à
mon avis est ce que ça participe à la
diffusion du virus de réfléchir à autre
chose télétravail ces travaux vont
pouvoir parler avec moi sur ce plateau
brigitte boucher de lcp-assemblée
nationale bonsoir s'agite et steve
jordan de public sénat bonsoir steve
steve c'est vous qui posez la première
question oui alexis corbière vous dites
qu'il faut écouter les scientifiques
officiellement il n'y a plus de
cinquante mille nouveaux cas de co vide
en france sur les dernières 24 heures le
professeur delfraissy par lui d'environ
cent mille cas à qui il faut faire
confiance
non mais que ce soit l'un ou l'autre
juste partant de cette assertion choisi
on est face à quelque chose de très
significatif dans mais ne demandez pas
un parlementaire sur ces grotesques
moi je suis j'ai fait des études
d'histoire vous la vérité qu'un
scientifique entre les deux noms mais la
vérité doit être entre les deux les deux
chiffres nous disent qu'à une évolution
très significative de toutes manières
et que les stratégies utilisées jusque
là n'endigue pas la progression de la
circulation du vieux c'est ce que moi je
comprends donc tout est stratégie un peu
par dans cette élection de couper y
compris la poire en deux en disant
continuer à aller travailler mais enfin
à partir de 21h tout ce qui est des
activités culturelles sportives n'en
fait plus par contre continué à aller
travailler ne fonctionnait pas aux
politiques de prendre les décisions vous
dites je m'en remets aux scientifiques
à un moment c'est mais là vous me
demander de trancher est-ce qu'on est à
cinquante mille ou cent mille dhs pardon
à la marque alors dit devant l'assemblée
nationale qui politiquement là vous
allez en moi si vous me demandez ce
qu'il faut faire je pense que nous
sommes arrivés à une situation mais je
répète en fonction de nos décisions qui
ont été prises ecoutez jean luc
mélenchon l'a répété quasiment comme un
gimmick il faut planifier planifié
planifié qu'elle planification aux
juments en terme de circulation de
masques notamment d'aller tester des
cessions l'assemblée nationale a adopté
la prolongation d'état d'urgence votre
groupe ne l'a pas votée il ya pas
urgence selon vous mais parce que voter
c'est donner un accord politique nous
avons voulu manifester par ce vote que
le désaccord quand nous allions de la
méthode pour le moment il ya assez peu
de débats et c'est d'ailleurs
regrettable moi je suis quand même à la
fois parlementaires et je défends le
parlementarisme le parlement times et la
possibilité de mettre en débat collectif
certaines décisions langue nous demande
de voter sans qu'il y ait un échange
c'est un échec de monsieur véran ne pas
avoir créé des conditions notamment de
multiplier les tests mais je parle pas
là des récemment depuis des mois pour
que les tests se multiplient et que les
masques soit multi placer le passé le
déclin non mais oui mais ça arrive à
tous les résultats mais ça c'est le
passé c'est des mauvaises décisions
politiques quelles stratégies d'isolde
d'isolement nous avions bon maintenant
recquois je termine en réquisitionnant
des hôtels par exemple lorsque nous
avions des cas de co vite pour que les
gens soient isolés cette stratégie n'a
pas été mise en oeuvre combien de lits
supplémentaires monsieur vers ans qui a
un style souvent tout ça est extrêmement
lui c'est nous sommes tous désignant
combien de lits supplémentaires ont été
faits vous êtes journée je vous le savez
comme moi aucune alimentation comment on
arrive à une situation de blocage on y
regardez monsieur corbières monsieur
mélenchon
que faut-il faire de la politique et
leur confinement
est-ce qu'il faut selon vous fermer les
établissements scolaires ou les laisser
ouverts
je pense que ce qu'il ya un confinement
évidemment les établissements scolaires
sont un lieu de circulation du virus
condamné la ba 112 qu'on va voir les
décisions qui sont prises on va écouter
les scientifiques mais si on va vers un
confinement je pense que ce confinement
ne doit plus être un confinement
de demi-mesure main confinement
significatif mais attention avec des
revenus de remplacement avec une aide
technique et jc vous faites pas dit
comment faire j'aurais témoin ce que je
ne vois pas c'est la leçon que je tire
de ces quelques semaines de 2000
confinement ça n'a pas bloqué la
circulation de tout le monde et moi
j'écoute les scientifiques nous disent
attention danger danger ceux qui sont en
première ligne dans les hôpitaux nous
disent voilà on est arrivé à 90 %
d'occupation des lits si je n'ai pas de
sothys tu crois que c'est le cas dans
mon département et c'est le cas dans
beaucoup de départements et des plans
blancs d avouer que ce serait un peu
curieux qu'en disant vas confiné mais
les jeunes vont continuer notre jeunesse
les enseignants vont continuer là il ya
quelque chose qui de mon point de vue
concret de cointe
mais là encore je vais écouter les
professionnels les spécialistes on va
voir mais si c'est une stratégie dont
souvent j'ai l'impression que c'est du
snes d'abord c'est à dire on est chez
rien n'impose le télétravail alors je
crois puis là et pas seulement on le
suscite tels que madame bornes le disait
l'encourager avec des mesures qui
n'était pas contraignante sur plan
juridique moi j'ai posé il faut autant
que possible tous les métiers permettent
pas le ténor voilà c'est possible
effectivement alors pourquoi pas donner
plus de pouvoir d'ailleurs aux salariés
au sein d'entreprises via les
différentes instances qui ont été
affaiblis que les salariés partout où
c'est possible que ce soit mis en place
je crois que là il faut une stratégie de
choc face à une situation qui est assez
préoccupante yves
[Musique]